on this thursday night the perilous
journey from afghanistan to canada my
family all very scared what afghans
approved to come to canada endure as
they escaped the taliban and the growing
fears for those left behind the crushing
impact of covid19 saskatchewan prepares
to airlift the critically ill we have
all of the plans in place to be able to
move people out of province and the
warning flu season could come back with
a vengeance
a royal objection it's very unnerving
the future king on climate change and
the billionaires focused on space
tourism and one audacious goal davies
takes it away the thrilling footwork
that put canada a step closer to the
world cup
[Applause]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with another major blow for
afghans trying to flee the taliban
including people approved to come to
canada not only is their country
collapsing economically it's now become
more difficult to escape pakistan
international airlines the only
international carrier with regular
flights from kabul has suspended flights
to islamabad pakistan one of the few
lifelines left it says interference by
the taliban made it too difficult to
operate
according to a canadian veterans group
seventeen hundred afghans who applied to
come to canada are still trapped in safe
houses in kabul those who attempt the
dangerous land route to pakistan must
have a passport to cross the border even
afghans approved to come to canada as
refugees are struggling to find a way
out
jeff semple is in islamabad pakistan
with tonight's top story jeff well donna
hundreds of afghans who supported
canada's military mission remain trapped
inside that country though some have
managed to escape across the border to
pakistan
[Music]
the pakistani capital is just a few
hours drive from taliban-controlled
afghanistan but the two countries feel
worlds apart to muhammad ishmael that's
me and 2009. ishmael worked for the
canadian forces in kandahar for six
years in charge of security at the base
your job was to keep the canadian forces
safe yes they nicknamed him captain
smiley white smiley
smiling like all the time i'm smiling i
mean a happy man but that smile faded
fast in august as the taliban rapidly
retook control some canadian veterans
advised ishmael to leave his home in
kandahar for kabul where the canadian
government was arranging a rescue flight
ishmael recorded this video outside the
airport standing for days waist deep in
sewage water crying out to the canadian
soldiers inside the gates more than a
thousand times
i call them i am a smiley captain smally
hey listen to me but nobody
nobody hear me ishmael received his
paperwork to come to canada but the
canadian government provided no help to
escape afghanistan
so for weeks he and his family hid every
day i sitting in the room
the kids and wife talk about that don't
go out
maybe that'd be dangerous for you my
family
are very scared and for good reason one
of his kandahar colleagues interpreter
nasir ahmed khawaja moved to edmonton in
2017. his brother muhammad an
interpreter for the british stayed
behind with his family in august the
taliban showed up at the door and took
him away the family found his body a few
hours later all of his body was burned
nobody was nobody can recognize his face
he leaves behind his wife and five
children the youngest was born days
after his death
i'm worried about those kids
his his wife
the seer applied in august to bring the
family to canada but hasn't received a
response canada has put those people at
risk this canadian veteran is raising
funds to provide safe houses for 1700
afghans who supported canadian troops
they've been approved to come to canada
they just they don't have a route out at
the moment
with few flights the veterans are slowly
shuttling refugees out of afghanistan by
road a 10 hour dangerous drive through
multiple taliban checkpoints and finally
across the border into pakistan
ishmael his wife and son checked into
this islamabad hotel joined by dozens of
others
who also supported canada's military
campaign interpreters cooks mechanics
and their families
most spend a few weeks here completing
paperwork biometric scans and kovid 19
tests
before finally booking their ticket for
a new life in canada i pray and say like
i'm very happy and now hopefully
inshallah go to the safe country but as
he heads to the airport ishmael's heart
is heavy his mind on those left behind
in afghanistan i asking for
canadian government
to please please help to those peoples
but those canadian veterans groups
driving afghans across the border have
just hit a new roadblock pakistan has
shut the door on refugees even those
carrying a letter from the canadian
government showing that they are
eligible to come to canada for now only
those with a canadian passport are
getting through
meaning most
are stuck
donna
such a dilemma jeff semple in islamabad
thank you in a statement global affairs
canada says it is urging countries in
the region to keep their borders open to
afghan refugees it says it's also
committed to keep working to help people
who are stuck saying we will not stop
before the remaining canadian citizens
permanent residents and their families
and the vulnerable afghan citizens who
supported our work in afghanistan and
wish to leave are able to depart
new cases of covet 19 across this
country appear to be on a downward trend
but saskatchewan is still struggling to
cope it now has the highest rate of
active cases of all the provinces 375
per 100 000 people saskatchewan also has
the lowest vaccination rate of all the
provinces only 62 percent of people have
had both shots nationally 71 percent of
people are fully vaccinated plans are
now being made to transfer critically
ill covenant patients out of
saskatchewan the province says it has
enough resources to treat 135 patients
in icu
but not anymore airlifts could soon
begin to ontario heather urix west
reports
a total of 24 health care workers from
the canadian armed forces the red cross
and newfoundland and labrador are now
helping alberta with its covet 19
response as healthcare providers we
are just ingrained with
wanting to help others and we feel a
deep connection with you know other
healthcare providers across the country
whether or not they're our immediate
colleagues or not the additional staff
has helped alberta expand its icu
capacity just as patient numbers are
beginning to fall
but a neighboring saskatchewan intensive
care units are struggling to keep up
with the number of patients sick with
covet 19. if we hit a certain threshold
of that number where we were close to
last weekend of
icu capacity then we'll start looking at
outer province that's we have all of the
plans in place to be able to move people
out of province if need be but we're not
there right now saskatchewan's health
minister says he spoke with his
counterpart in ontario wednesday and
that ontario has agreed to accept
saskatchewan patients as soon as there
is need but the canadian medical
association says the province needs
stronger public health measures in place
as well i think gathering limits are
really critical at this point i think
they also really do need to give strong
consideration to a circuit breaker they
have pushed their health care system to
the edge of collapse and the only way to
really bring numbers down quickly is to
limit close contact saskatchewan waited
until mid-september to implement an
indoor mask mandate while its vaccine
passport system only began on october
1st and that has been good enough for us
to get a plateauing
but
not sufficient to see us get that rapid
decline that we'd like to see in order
to take pressure off our system and
unlike alberta saskatchewan imposed no
gathering limits over thanksgiving
leaving many in the medical community
fearing that a bad situation here could
soon become worse
heather urex west global news calgary
one of the blessings of the pandemic has
been the huge drop in flu cases but as
people gather indoors again and go to
school and work cold and flu season
could come back with a vengeance jamie
morocco explains what doctors are
expecting and what you can do to protect
yourself
most parents will do anything to keep
their baby happy
but when your child is sick mom of two
sheila furetto will tell you it's a
whole other ball game getting an illness
this in this day and age kind of just
throws your whole world into a tailspin
last year thanks to pandemic measures
the chance of getting a colder flu was
low in 2020 2021 canada saw just 69
cases of influenza a shocking drop from
the previous six years which averaged
around 52 thousand cases given the lack
of influenza this past year
it means nobody's been very recently
exposed and yeah that means we could
have a very worrisome spike not only in
our numbers but in the severity of those
cases for alberta and saskatchewan where
critical care systems are already
overwhelmed an aggressive flu season
could be devastating for icus the
solutions may seem familiar
washing your hands staying home when
you're sick and getting the flu vaccine
these vaccines they're not
fantastic in terms of preventing all
infections but they're moderate which is
good and that itself will impact on
the number of people who get severely
ill from influenza and require
hospitalization doctors say the flu shot
is safe for everyone vaccinated against
covet 19 and it's even safe to get both
a flu shot and a covet 19 jab at the
same time this is the high dose vaccine
it's the best one for the seniors at
this toronto pharmacy where flu shots
are already being dispensed for
high-risk patients they're offering both
because they're both respiratory
infections
we really want to mitigate that and just
keep
the infection rates low with
three-month-old everett not yet eligible
for the flu shot favreto is anxious to
get hers i'll be first in line i'll be
bringing my three-year-old with me and
then as soon as everett turns six months
we'll be looking for him to get
vaccinated against the flu as well she
says it's her best chance to keep her
family healthy and avoid the sleepless
nights that come with a sick kid tammy
morocco global news toronto
a bit of political news we still don't
know who will make up the cabinet of the
newly elected liberal government but
multiple reports say the swearing-in
will be october 25th the prime minister
has already said christia freeland will
continue to serve as finance minister
and deputy prime minister it's unclear
who else will get to keep their jobs
justin trudeau says he is committed to
maintaining gender parity
investigators released their findings
into that catastrophic fire in linton
d.c coming up why some residents are
furious plus prince william blasts the
billionaire space race
the nunavut government is helping with
the water emergency in ocala wheat the
first shipment of clean water has now
arrived by plane ocalaweets mayor kenny
bell tells global news about 30 thousand
of the 80 000 leaders expected arrived
today and was gone quickly the capital
of nunavut is under a state of emergency
after the water supply was deemed unsafe
to drink or cook with because it may be
contaminated with petroleum nearly 9 000
residents scrambled to find clean water
some filling up jugs at temporary fill
stations and even in nearby lakes and
rivers
the people of litton bc were hoping for
answers about what sparked that
devastating wildfire that ripped through
town this summer some residents believed
sparks from a passing train ignited it
but today the transportation safety
board said it could not find a link as
nithu garcia reports it's little comfort
to all the people who lost their homes
and businesses
oh my god look at that
an entire community devastated burned to
the ground and two lives lost and now
investigators say they found no evidence
that trains running near litton were
responsible refuting residents
allegations about sparks flying from the
railway igniting the dry terrain during
record heat there are so many so many
families that are just on the edge right
now and
this news is a kick when we're down
kevin loring who now lives in ottawa was
born and raised in litton he says most
of his family has been left homeless the
house i grew up in is in the center of
town
my that's my mom's house he says he's
furious over the findings saying key
eyewitnesses weren't questioned as part
of the tsb's investigation we did not
have any direct interviews with any
resident of litton if you have
eyewitnesses to the account
uh of what started the the fire and you
don't interview them how can you
possibly come to the conclusion that you
do for the lead investigator to come out
say that there's no conclusive evidence
you have to wonder if they're not
captured by the industry that they're
supposed to oversee the report says when
investigators searched for signs of hot
bearings burnt break heads built up
tread and other potential fire creating
causes they found no anomalies and after
taking samples of coal-like substances
it was found they have little in common
with what the locomotives carry
load testing was also conducted which
simulates the operation of the
locomotive and no sparking was noted
we're willing to reopen it if we get
compelling evidence what more compelling
evidence do you need that the fire
originated uh you know adjacent to the
train tracks
during the time a passing cold train is
moving through town the rcmp and bc
wildfire service are continuing to
investigate but for now the tsb says
it's met its mandate and isn't
speculating on other possible causes i
can speak for a lot of litanites that we
have very little faith in the findings
of the transportation safety board and
we are incredibly disappointed
global news
prince william has taken a shot at rich
entrepreneurs competing to send tourists
to space he says they should focus
instead on ways to repair and protect
the planet
we need
some of the world's greatest brains and
minds fixed on trying to repair this
planet not trying to find the next place
to go and live
it was a swipe by the future king at
billionaires jeff bezos elon musk and
richard branson who are all vying to
usher in a new era of private commercial
space travel the interview also airs a
day after william shatner's trip to the
stars prince william's first earth shot
winners will be announced on sunday five
projects offering innovative inspiring
solutions to climate change will get 1.6
million dollars to pursue their plans
still ahead the deadly protest sparked
by the investigation into beirut's port
explosion
in southern taiwan at least 46 people
are dead and dozens more injured after a
fire at a high-rise building it happened
early this morning there are reports it
was home to many poor elderly and
disabled people an investigation into
the cause is underway
and in beirut gunfire broke out in the
lebanese capital where there's intense
anger about the investigation into last
year's huge explosion at the city's port
at least six people were killed dozens
more injured it is the most violent
street fighting in beirut in years some
people fled their homes and school
children ducked for cover as armed
fighters exchanged fire for hours with
automatic rifles and rocket-propelled
grenades the lebanese army eventually
arrested at least nine people anger has
been building since the iran-backed
hezbollah militia and its shiite allies
demanded the removal of the judge
investigating the port explosion saying
the whole thing has become politicized
the victims families support the judge's
work
nobody has been held responsible for the
august 2020 blast that killed 219 people
a fire ignited more than 2 700 tons of
ammonium nitrate that had been
improperly stored for years
lebanon's month-old government has been
facing pressure to get to the bottom of
the blast and deal with lebanon's
worsening economic crisis
a danish man is in custody after a night
of terror in a norwegian town a man shot
people with a bow and arrow a crime
norwegian police say was terrorism five
people are dead including four women
many of the victims were targeted in a
supermarket in a small town near
norway's capital oslo a 37-year-old man
is in custody police say the suspect had
converted to islam and was previously
flagged as having been radicalized they
believe he acted alone police say the
suspect is cooperating but there's no
word on a motive
bend it like davies next could this
soccer star be canada's ticket to the
world cup
alfonso davies keeps it obsessed
davies are you kidding me
it's no secret he is one of the best but
that goal by canada's alfonso davies in
last night's world cup qualifier against
panama was so astonishing even the
announcer could hardly believe it from
the way he raced to the ball stole it
from under the feet of a defender and
then buried it in the net there is a
reason it's being called one of the
greatest moments ever in canadian men's
soccer there are more world cup
qualifier games to come and as eric
sorenson reports the canadian men's team
is ready
canada's greatest it starts with alfonso
davies pure unmatched speed from where
he is on the pitch davies races past
everyone to keep the ball inbound david
plays it down the line look out that
ball steak in and davies is on it davies
takes it away
and then it's davey's pure soccer
instincts a tour de force of soccer
skill the likes of which canadian men's
soccer has never seen before
an
individual piece of brilliance coming in
game we knew how to win this game you
know to keep our walk-up hopes alive and
which we did davey's personal story is
even more awe-inspiring born in this
refugee camp in ghana his family came to
edmonton when he was five he began
playing soccer and dreaming my goal is a
play to reach a professional level
he reached the professional level at age
15 with the vancouver whitecaps then on
to one of the world's elite teams
germany's bayern munich where he has won
championships
it's just it's remarkable to watch and
it's fun as a fan because we've honestly
never seen it for decades canada has
seen only futility on the international
stage
honduras wins the match 2-1 four years
ago canada once again could not even
make this region's six team qualifying
playoffs this year canada is not only in
the tournament but has just jumped ahead
of panama into third place and it's the
top three teams that will qualify for
next year's world cup that's something
canada hasn't done since 1986 and now is
one step closer what you've seen tonight
is everything combined the heart the
spirit the talent
it's a proud night for our for our
country the inspiration of christine
sinclair and women's soccer and
development of the men's game with
talent like jonathan david and taejang
buchanan is causing support to mushroom
for canadian fans and players who dream
like alfonso davies did i think you're
seeing now
more people getting an opportunity to
play this game and having the ability to
see themselves in the bright lights
lights that are shining brightly on this
player and this team not yet a soccer
power but getting there
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this former sask wheat
pool elevator in flaxcomb saskatchewan
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]